and welcome to this video this is the
revenue video of this week of yeah
themed openings and it was the Kings
fianchetto week so I did fianchetto
King's Bishop and all of the games
usually starting with g3 or g6 and then
Bishop to next move
yeah let's have a look at how this went
in terms of rating it wasn't okay week
it was some about even I started with
about 2,400 and finished like that
results were okay but well the results
as you know in blitz are not always
related to the opening result so let's
just have a review and also buy that get
a feel for for for those kind of
openings what is going on there we will
start off with white yeah and well it
says ever started g3 basically in in all
games and we had a wide variety of
things that came from this simply
because it is highly transpositional GC
g3 in itself is not yeah not let's say
standalone opening it's mostly a
transpositional thing there is something
called the Banco opening which is one g3
but this is basically limited to things
like I had one game that went like this
I think it's more to do they have two
games like that I think one just the one
game against doctor none if I go now
like d3 this would be really that what
is called the Banco opening where yeah
we are talking about the reversed modern
or reversed builds defense which is
really quite tame and not very ambitious
white I'm playing like that is basically
giving up any idea form for an opening
edge you can do that but it is not very
very inspiring I tried to see form in
one of the games here against the doctor
nun who played c6 yeah which is of
course good Black has a number of moves
and very often they transposed to other
things deform for example is very likely
transposing to some kind of Reggie
opening which let's say like d3 here and
here which could easily rise by a night
at 3:00 on the first movement then d5
see for D form yeah so like let's say
like this yeah which is in effect a
reverse benoni
yeah there are tons of those trans
positions in fact here also Knight f6 is
possible which after C takes Knight
takes is all of a sudden in English
opening so it's it's highly
transpositional in the game doctor none
when c6 which is also a main move really
and now I took and when d4 which i think
is the best way to play for white you
should get some kind of play in the
center not just play d3 and be passive
yeah here black has two main options he
can take on default play for he took
possible but a thought a form is more
testing and I checked it a little bit in
my database this is the more more
interesting move actually gaining space
and trying to to blunt this Bishop white
probably should do something like that
yeah trying to attack the center Pony
only four and either force black to
trade which gives white a little bit
development advantage yeah Center is a
bit problematic here those squares here
a bit tricky but it's good development
or black can try to support that with f5
after which white has this kind of idea
sometimes Bishop g5 in case of nine f6
leads an interesting play
I don't like it particularly much for
white because um yeah black has a space
advantage and I don't like to have a
space disadvantage is white which is
some yeah well I committed to play this
openings for just four varieties sake
but it's nothing that I particularly
like yeah and he took however on d4 and
to that and I think white has a decent
position here and the most testing
continuation however it's not what he
played he played Nazi 609 f6 I need to
look that up it's not a huge difference
I think black should probably try to
play with a check here maybe intending
to return the pawn like that this is
very comparable to um to the pawn off
attack against the pro/con or the c4 c6
c4 line um black is probably okay yeah
but this is not something that varies by
to much you can take here on d3 and on
what can even play for a sacrifice
because he's so well developed black is
making pawn moves on all the time so
this whole line seems to be okay
actually for white if you don't mind
this type of position I do mind it but
this is also a personal preference thing
in general if you play the move one g3
and they go e5 it is a very decent idea
to not play Bishop g2 in the first place
but to play C form n transposed to the
English opening which would normally
come up by a c4 e v g3 I think this is a
very good idea and probably objectively
the move that lets white fight for the
most here out of the opening
it's also quite logical to try to
prevent the perfect pawn Center with e4
and d4 of course that is not a mistake
or anything I mean well I played a
couple of games with colors reversed
being a tempo down and well you can do
that but I think trying to go for an
advantage you better go go seafoam here
but I didn't want to transpose into pure
English openings too much just to keep
it in to keep it in character at same in
some games two games they went g6 yeah
which is quite popular if the people
fianchetto themselves yeah they like
they play the Kings Indian or other
fianchetto type openings they very often
just yeah copy what you do and here we
have a branch parting of the ways in in
one game I went for and then two
I played c4 so I got that quite quite a
bit Evo is interesting yeah it looks a
bit weird yeah why would you block the
bishop but it prepares further
occupation in the center and possibly
exactly the setup that I got I had one
game where black know when c5 which
looks quite logical and we got got a
Sicilian type of position now I know
something like that is what what we had
26 I mean castles 97 c3 yeah this setup
is quite interesting it's a very often
called the big clamp don't know really
where that comes from but it's it's
quite nice I think this is something
that I could easily imagine yeah playing
in in a in a serious game like this why
this harmoniously developed he's got
good central control with those pawns it
looks a little bit like a let's say yeah
like a reversed
Dutch defense in a way aware we're in
the Dutch it would be black but you get
an F or F for this perfect Pandu and
okay black is not in terrible shape yeah
but that is certainly an interesting way
to play and you can easily get a nice
position if like is playing some some
second second rate continuations yeah
and in the game that I that I had for
example he played far too slowly on the
queenside
and with with d4 and later he five I got
a very nice position this setup for
example also was used by a Viktor
Korchnoi in one of his world
championship games again sunnatullah'
Karpov winning a nice game I think it
was in the 1978 World Championship match
on the Philippines not sure how Kapoor
played but I think he also went for this
black setup and I think this is an
interesting alternative to go with with
this efore move here instead of instead
of c4 black is not forced to too
see five of course yeah you can also
play something like let's say e five you
can just copy that but well white can
can try something something similar this
can easily transpose into into a kind of
Vienna game yeah from e4 e5 Knight c3
but that's an interesting offbeat way to
play a later d3 f4 so why not it's um
it's a possible opening c4 I played two
times and both times they went for a c5
come going completely symmetrical yeah
here White's main continuation is Knight
f3 but I did not go for that
um yeah to be perfectly honest I think
that in this kind of situation after
Knight f3 um black doesn't have any
particular problem with many moves the
main reason for that is that black has
this very nice grip over D form and why
it does not get to play D form anytime
soon of course white is not worse but
it's not very aggressive let's say from
White's point of view it does not get in
d4 early and in fact being let's say a
tempo down in this in this symmetrical
position or let's say yeah let's say
black sees White's move first actually
it's a bit helpful because when after
9003 we know the knight is there and now
we can play accordingly for example um
yeah II 5 is very often better played
when the night is already committed to
to f3 so um it's nothing I like
particularly it's an okay position for
white but it's nothing nothing great I
went a 3 here and well this is also not
not much to write home about but it has
a little bit of white with a quick look
B 1 + B form I had as mentioned two
games with that and in both games black
reacted with the a pawn in one game they
played a six just being symmetrical this
is the main line actually
which is to be honest a little bit
boring
this is this thing this is actually what
deters me from from going into that as
white and in serious games because it's
just really boring it seems however that
after Knight f3 this extra tempo is
giving white maybe maybe a little bit of
an advantage it is very very yeah it's
it's not much but you have some some
hope that something like this and 95
that you can do something with the tempo
it is very safe in any case yeah if
you're looking for a very safe line for
what this is certainly fitting the bill
after 86
um there is very little that white can
do besides this rupee one before idea
otherwise III really didn't make it
didn't make much sense a 6 is the most
solid move for black but also as I said
a little bit boring one a three black
has other trials that are more
interesting or a little bit let's say
more flexible and fighting an
interesting one for example is b6 this
is what I have played myself angling for
quick Bishop d7 d6 Queen d7 and then
later is 697 so just yeah black has to
start with b6 to get the Queen said she
had to win in the first place
that's a bit more interesting from next
point of view um what the other guy did
was a5 that that's not very common
committing to that so early being a bit
of an ugly bit of an ugly move here
because b5 is weakened however the
position is fairly closed and it is not
really clear that white is coming up
what can come up with anything very
dangerous I went in this game I went a
three and I thought that man it might be
a good idea to have this setup like with
92 castles of course not bad but I was
surprised that if I
yeah which I thought during the game
isn't that great is in fact quite okay
um like it doesn't have any particular
problem here I thought this set up with
night on e two would be a little bit
better in comparison to set up with
Knight f3 where you often go all night
f3 e 1 C 2 e 3 t 5 yeah takes a long
while until you get in 95 immediately
but it's it turned out that as it is in
the game here this is looking nice but
it's nothing special really I
automatically got a good position but
that was not really due to the opening I
mean I think still think that this is a
little bit better than the Knight f3 e1
version of the whole opening but still
black is very solid here he has
relatively good you can fight for d5
quite well and it's not so easy for
white to get anywhere pretty solid
pretty solid f5 looks a bit a bit yeah a
bit crude but it's not it's not bad it
seems um yeah what else did I get g3
Knight f6 was one game of course very
flat flexible Bishop g2 and g6 yeah yeah
here white again it has a pretty wide
choice C for D for some transpositional
possibilities I tried to move b3 which
is a bit uncommon here but it's it does
not seem to be particularly bad my
opponent played Bishop g7 after that
after which we got a position that
normally comes up via the reti opening I
like we had this this is normally coming
out via the reti 95 d5 see for one night
f3 d5 g36c for this kind of thing um it
turned out that he played that just
identical to how dr. Nam played against
me recently like here twin c2 and rupee
and in that game I played 95 to which
she reacted badly I mean my opponent
here mr. it was it was called legend
legend 2014 yeah dr. nanny took and
Wendy for which seems to be a yeah okay
or the best best driver black and now I
have checked this a little bit and I
think that 95 while not being terrible
probably should be replaced by another
move interesting ideas if a white and
Knight c3 for example that's pretty
interesting after an e5 C takes he takes
Knight b5 is basically winning four
right so he cannot do that has to take
her the night and now White has some
chances for an advantage simply because
we have a kind of English opening or
also it's a little of a bit likely
reverse dragon where where black has
played a pretty passive setup a night on
d7 c6 and so on
White has some chances for a slight
advantage here you have the two center
points that are not yet in effect but
they they are useful to have and they
might come up later another good idea is
to just go d4 n transpose into some kind
of Grune fault structure where black is
committed to two early moves that are
not super active
probably this is better in terms of
fighting for an opening advantage what I
did is okay but it's it's not very it's
not very powerful let's say yeah what
else did I get
let me check with white yeah I got one
g3 f5
Bishop g2 Knight f6 and I went c4 of
course white can also play d4 and just
transposed to a leningrad touch again
here d4 as a landing at touch 7 d3 I
went with d3 castles c4 this what
Winnick setup yeah this is a pretty good
line against
the Dutch if you had not committed to
deform it leads to a position that is
more more of a strategic nature in the
game black went with that taking and
pony five and got a decent position
yeah like d6 h3 Bishop d6 95 and now the
interesting moves Knight to d7 97 to c5
yeah I still think that White has a
slight advantage in this position
because some white some enjoying more
space as the knight on d5 and it's not
so clear what what blacks plan is in the
game I miss played and I miss played
them advance on the Queen Sun and gave
black an excellent position it was kind
of an up-and-down experience but in
general I think that against the the
Dutch set up here that the then Ingrid
Dutch set up let's say with g6 this d3
form can be an interesting way to get
together an unique position and not
transpose into regular Dutch that also
can easily come up from the English
opening c-45 if we yeah like here here
this is how he played and it could
easily be em yeah in a different move
order that black starts with E 596 g6
and later on f5 this is in fact that the
main moves order there yeah what else
did I get
of course I got d5 the g3 d5 main move
and yeah I played Bishop d2 and Knight
f3 here umm can be transpositional
however Bishop g2 of course allows a 5
as an earlier set I don't regard that to
be particularly grateful white you can
play D 3 and C 4 but probably Knight f3
is the somewhat more ya ambitious choice
just preventing a5 I got one game which
was interesting there the first one in
the session where black went f6 after
which after d4 we had some kind of a
river
moonflower type of position in fact here
quite often it gets to be a reverse
Greenfeld knight c6 d4 for example is
quite a quite a good line for white um
it's nothing overwhelming if black knows
what what he's doing but it's quite nice
especially if black is not knowing what
he is doing
for example the reversed green felt
proper is rather dangerous for black
because the extra tempo is quite
relevant in the fight against the center
it is very transpositional this reversed
green for example after Knight f6
castles east six c4 we can easily get
cat and an opening or a Queen's Gambit
arash
so g3 is a super transposition and move
especially if widest playing somewhat
ambitiously and not just yeah playing
for like d3 g3 some kind of schematic
approach if he plays ambitiously it is
it is it is theoretical it's not a non
theoretical line I also got got this g6
no sorry c6 Bishop g2 g 6 cancels Bishop
g7 when I went c4 yeah that's that's ok
interesting way to play and they took it
on c4 that was one of the games that I
lost quite quite badly I went a 4 in
that game I didn't know that line at all
I went a 493 and we got a very strange
position we had this this thing it was a
very very weird game yeah here which was
completely on cam yeah I checked that a
bit and it seems that white maybe should
go for 93 it's not exactly on the
forefront of theory a discus line it's
it's very rare but night a 3s may be a
better choice trying to get it back
black has to be a very
yeah very cautious with with stuff like
that yeah for example this is a way to
to play against that if he covers it
like in the game with Bishop e6 now 95
is a much better alternative as here I
even can go back if I want yeah
even though even the capture on d5 is a
better version compared to the game
because a four it's not really necessary
in that in that sequence of moves yeah I
mean here in the game we had the same
thing with Knight f6 and a4 inserted no
a 4 and a 4 is kind of pointless him
better is not H 311 so I think night a3
here is is the better choice compared to
a 4 probably white can maybe fight for a
little something
it's nothing brilliant but it is
definitely ok the other thing that I got
here with g5 was I got I got this kind
of thing yeah I got that that 2 times of
course some anisette transpositional
this is the Catalan but b3 is
transporting into into the red team and
I got one game there where they played
with a 5 and c6 I was some yeah it was
like that
III p5 and and in the game I was a bit
skeptical about that setup and said that
probably weakens the queenside and it's
not that great for black yeah it's
checked it a little bit and it seems
that this is playable for black doesn't
seem to be any problem there with it it
does weaken the Queen side a little bit
but White has no real way forward black
seems to be fine it might be that white
has to improve somewhere the easiest
approach is of course to just go to them
to the Catalan with d4 while a or let's
say after a 5 maybe then maybe then
before they have a four I don't know if
that's so great no it's an interesting
way from black to to approach that it is
a five move after Knight c3 that's also
differ that's something to be aware of
not be five maybe interesting line it's
63 that also might be an idea
I didn't look too closely am in the
second game that that reached this
position black took one c4 where is that
actually no we went no sorry he started
with that I went Bishop b2 and now it
took on c4 I think this is just not very
accurate white seems to maintain a
slight advantage after that move it
seems better to do play just 96 and here
white mostly goes with III preparing
Queen e2 after which black has the
choice between playing d4 leading some
can to some kind of reverse benoni
or going with the capture and play
something like sorry sorry the capture
is a bit early I think b6 fb6 Queen e2
and now maybe taking or do you start
with Bishop d7 like this some are like
this and now taking and taking at one
point this is somehow black normally
normally plays that the early capture
that was played in in in my game here
has some drawbacks it gives white a good
diagonal and an extra center for that is
back but it's still relevant and can
come up later I went with 95 and I think
this is a good simple continuation that
will always give white a slight edge
it's just that the bishop on g2 is a
strong piece B file gets relevant later
why there's a little bit better here
this is not a great way to play for
black capture away from the center it's
just violating sorry it's just violating
stupid to do that just violating this
rule that you should not capture away
from the center I know that I showed a
line early
black is doing that but in that he gets
some counter play on the defund and
against his three white already had
played a three-year yeah in the
comparable position just to make the
comparison like here yeah here taking is
actually giving black ideas yeah on the
three are on the D pawn if white plays
d4 we got hanging pawns and an entirely
different structure so um that's that's
a better better way to play yeah in
general I like my wide opening results
it was okay it's something that I have
some experience and I have a fair share
of experience with with this move order
which is quite often leading to to the
same thing yeah as I said quite often
after one g3 white wants to play Knight
f3 early on to make sure that if v is
not coming so this is a pretty pretty
good way to open so let's look at the
black side no going to turn this round
yeah I played g6 Bishop g7 in all-black
games and it's quite surprising that um
yeah maybe not but I wasn't wrong so
clear beforehand for me that it would
turn out to be like that I had really
good results really good results which
is probably also due to the opponent's
playing strengths but I had really good
results in this positions where White
was not going to c4 yeah like here or
here in those are actually squad close
to 100% and got really nice positions
out of the opening and was was really a
very unsatisfying yes I have a look
let's start with that had very bad
results with c4
included let's start with that I had one
game here where it went with c5 c3 takes
takes here this is actually quite
comparable to what we had with colors
reversed yeah if you remember we
had this thing with g3 Bishop g2 C for
attacking the center this is the same
thing colors reversed one temple down
and here again I think why should think
about advancing this is also what what
he did in the game in my my opponent and
I kind of screwed up this in the
printout where was that is it here yeah
okay
Bishop p.m. and I think he played it in
a bit in a bit bit slow fashion there
with white probably should be five
checks a good idea here he did not go
for that he played something rather
passive Bishop e3 is what he did and
then we should be too this is better I
think
chanting giving blackness this
problematic pawn structure and then
trying to maybe play for this square or
for possible pressure on on the pawn
this is I think the way to go for white
but it did not happen he played this
kind of thing Bishop here knight c6
Bishop e2 and talked and went e6 and he
I think black is already in quite good
shape because the default form isn't
target and it gets to be attacked quite
often also with f6
the Bishop 1 a3 is the bishop that
basically constitutes the bishop pair
why it's extra bishop in a way compared
to a knight but it's not just it's all a
good piece it just looks at blacks pawns
and just nothing Black is very ok in
this position so this was a good opening
result however I think far more critical
here is this check check it's also
scoring quite well for white so this is
probably something that makes this line
a bit a bit tricky the thing that also
should be mentioned is that here white
has a good continuation with D takes d5
that's actually the best move I just
played this for variety sake but I was
risking quite a bit here because this is
a good line
for white if you play the white side of
this and you can easily get this
position from this position from various
move orders also let's say let's see you
Andy for player with white and you play
like this and they go here you have the
same position and it can happen and
taking is actually quite good for white
the problem is that if black wants to
get the pawn back he has to check and
after the move Knight to a3 black has
very serious problems to equalize one
key point is that the pawn snatcher is
it's not playable and black is actually
losing almost by force
that's a terrible position yeah there's
a check threatened here and your queen
is strapped yeah 93 is basically
shutting out the Queen there's also
other moves that are strong but Knight
c3 is the best one intending Bishop
cancels Bishop b2 and the Queen is
trapped it's really completely busted
yeah so black cannot take on c3 and this
means that he has to deal with that
point Bishop e3 and not b5 and black
already has to make some kind of yeah it
has to be very carefully and not to lose
quickly it's um it's a rather fishy no
and it was a very risky thing to to try
out him I had a couple of games where
this happened and now white went for
various things there was no game with f4
surprisingly this formerly main move
from was not played against me and I'm
not going to review it now black has
mostly the choice between yes staying
within modern territory like with a 6 b5
very very sharp or Knight f6 going back
into a more conservative thing like this
is the pearls defense
and a bit more solid than a 6 b 5 at
least it develops a piece and I got this
a number of times and heck excellent
results with it with this a6 move
intending b5 I looked it up and it seems
that whites most popular movie is
actually a 4 and I have to say I like
that best yeah why not just prevent b5 a
4 makes make sense
in case of b6 which I tried in one game
let's start with that actually yes I'll
just be six in that case white always
has this a5 idea in the mix somewhere
yeah black is setting up the
hippopotamus I got I got one one game
like that and I think this is one of
them better hippopotamus setups black is
only very slightly worse with this space
disadvantage but in fact due to the
somewhat tame white setup it seems that
he gets his hippopotamus set up in the
first place and maybe can get some
central counter play in so I don't think
that the hippopotamus is in that form is
any is a huge problem for black it just
it's a matter of taste it's not
everybody's cup of tea of course I got
one game where they allowed this thing
and played a three here I think black
has a very really nice position and it
showed very nicely how good blacks or
how rewarding black setup can become if
white is playing in a Midway there was
one game where they really played like
Bishop here here and I got in a quick c5
let me have a look there where was that
b5 a3 Bishop e7 Bishop here 97 Queen DS
to see fire there should be two takes
bishop took strangely enough Knight f6
and here black has an excellent position
yeah I have this Sicilian like set up
without any tempo loss yeah c5 was
played in one move taking on
four and white has a very unambitious
set up yeah
h3 a three yeah and well in this I mean
they opened the salient black does have
an extra center pawn and play on the C
file yeah there's this famous saying if
black black is black has equalized in
the Sicilian then he's better it's by
tall and very it's a very decent thing
to say because quite often is it it is
like that if black is not worse out of
the opening like he gets killed right
away in the Sicilian quite often he is
better because of his strategic
advantages of the extra center pawn and
CFL play flexibility and so on and here
we have a Sicilian type of position type
of structure where white setup doesn't
make much sense and I have one that
quickly due to a blunder black is
already in very very nice shape
I had a comparable game actually wear
white started here I played f3 96 which
would be 3 97 2025 and now white went
Knight h3 yeah this is in fact played
quite a bit it's not what a rare move in
comparison I thought that g4 or h4 is
more interesting just playing you know
in a super and in a more aggressive
fashion still angling for long casting
is more ambitious he he went in my game
he went like this and this I was kind of
surprised actually found games with that
bye-bye grandmasters and I think they
played it play it ok I'm sorry
actually here this this this I found and
there were games were white played with
a quick a for this is in fact far more
interesting than the other set up that
we had because he would f3 white center
pawn is supported and with a form white
is trying to make use of the fact that
blacks advanced pawns can also be a
weakness this is a playable playable
option for white in the game that
he played out every played far too
passively like that and after this I
again with castles D 5v5 I got got a
very nice very nice game out of it
so this c5 approach combined with g6 can
lead to very nice versions of the
Sicilian if white is not playing very
very ambitiously ok let me look at my
printout there
what else did I get yeah dad I think
these are that's all of the pure evil
positions yep
yeah let's now look at the more d4c for
lacking positions I got this okay one
once I had had one game with that and I
checked that this is actually very nice
for black I mean not very nice it's a
bit strong yeah it's not that black is
clearly bad or anything but this
somewhat um slowish dude up with d4
Knight f3 g3 um it's um it's um it is
not ambitious and with c5 like very
quickly gets a nice game ahead this in
one game and was very very ok I really
like my position there I won that game
quite quickly which was not necessary of
course white is not clear diverse or
anything but in general I think black
can be very satisfied with the outcome
of this opening as white has played his
Knight quite a bit black has a extra
center pawn and it would open diagonal
there with the bishop on g7 I think this
is already em yeah quite quite okay in
terms of Equalization I actually found
games where black quite quickly pushed
h5 in this position is quite quite a
funny idea going for 4h for ya it's it's
it's a way to make use of the fact that
black has not committed to any castling
yet and yeah h4 sometimes even queen 85
h5 is in it's interesting and quite
active
this seems to be a an argument against
those slowish buildups in fact also the
London system against this g6 Bishop g7
is relatively meek as a quick c5 Queen
b6 is okay amongst others is also a d6
9075 kind of setup there the night is
still back there so against g6 Bishop g7
them this queen pawn openings without c4
lose lots of sting I got this I got this
a number of times and had my fair share
of problems with it one reason was that
that I think actually the best move here
for black is 9 f6 just going to the
King's Indian but I felt should stay
within the modern defense kind of
territory so I tried other moves but I
didn't fare well and I think it's mostly
I mean it's just you to mine my not very
my bad play but it's also not that great
there's bishop g form that has been
played a bit as an alternative but
ultimately it mostly leads to positions
where black gives up his bishop pair and
has to ya show compensation for it i got
one game against against mr. oleg us
where went knight c6 here here c5 takes
takes here white is just slightly better
it's just like that it's an open
position he has the bishop pair and
better center better central control
- better that wasn't very nice and I
looked it up I think maybe 697 trying to
go D 65 is better but still I would like
to be whitey and comparison the bishop
pair is just quite good Bishop g4 it's
not particularly great in another game I
went here c5 and got got this thing
against webmaster bachmann from paraguay
yeah here I got a very bad Ben Oni type
of position which he however screwed up
really quickly I went here and he got an
F for Nate I had a good position I
checked that actually this year check
has been played by some good players and
now f5 the the best player I found there
was was Grandmaster mala Hoff from
Russia is the 2700 player it's not a
very active player so maybe you don't
don't know him but it's a very strong GM
here 2007 something all of the time and
this is interesting it's very comparable
to the to the ginchy Indian where black
also takes on c3 in opening that I would
have tried but I didn't get the proper
move order to play it running I think
yeah interesting here black has damaged
White's pawn structure can try to play
and those pawns it's a bit risky at two
knights against two bishops always a
strategic risk but White's pawn
structure is quite damaged maybe this is
better than what I did my position here
wasn't great I went here just played
let's say normally here was worse I mean
if I just sit around and worse and after
year six and now I know g4 f5 I was
worse yeah that is not not really really
great I got I got this and also and
tried a couple of things
I tried e5 2 times and I lost both games
but one was very good for me one was
this which is not great really this is
just leading to a good position for
black off let's say a very good
equalizing chances position my opponent
played this move which is just terrible
and I got a winning position very early
this this this
in this kind of this kind of thing I had
a fantastic person there why should play
here and go back and here black is okay
but it's nothing nothing terrible for
what maybe you should go to f2 I don't
know
but how better here are other moves like
Knight f3 92 or D 5 D 5 was played
against me by Grand Master dashi Kiran
and after a 5 Bishop III here we got
this position and I went for Bishop h6
I checked that that this position has
been played a couple of times and with
hindsight and Bishop h6 was rubbish
anyway but with hindsight I probably
should start with something like that
and only later commit to do if I want to
go Bishop h6 or f5 him it's a fairly
normal position that is quite comparable
to King's Indian if I play Knight f6 we
actually would transpose to a Kings
Indian but probably not the most precise
form for black and it's a bit if you
have to play Knight f6 you should have
played the King's Indian in the first
place I'd like to get in f5 years
somehow quicker yeah here here white
seems to have a slight advantage no
matter what but it's not it's not the
end of the road Bishop h6 and this Queen
h4 where played really really wasn't
that great I got one game with that and
here I tried I tried two things I had
one get one with that that one with that
I'm sorry one with that setup after
which my opponent played Bishop g5 he
actually suffered a very bad loss but
this is probably due to the fact that I
went 97 which in itself is not terrible
but I really played badly afterwards it
seems that the more King's Indian like
move Nydia 6 is much better it seems to
be very ok and here white doesn't have
to be white doesn't have anything
anything special in fact the early
Bishop g5 might even be questionable in
some cases yeah they'd say like here
here and now Bishop III I have this is
early jump to the reform yeah this would
have been much better than my 97 which
are already suspected during the game I
had one game that went like this and he
I was really surprised by my my survey
my research after the game I always
thought that this should be okay for
black because you get in f5s early but
it's not quite clear if this is really
helping black in the game I played f5
this and after Knight f6 takes I played
this which essentially loses after
Bishop h5 i summer won that game but it
didn't really relate to the opening it
seems that I have to play Knight f5 here
which looks a bit wrong let's aim here
because you give up the e4 square but in
return you get default for your knight
so it seems to be not that bad at all in
fact flex results here have been quite
ok even though it was just a couple of
games black can try to start with h6
trying to prevent 95 and only now go and
5 but again the capture seems good
because after pawn takes 9h form this
check is very annoying so this early f5
seems to be quite ambitious ok you can
do it but you have to take with the
night it seems that any try to recapture
with the pawn is just not not solid
enough it just doesn't seem to doesn't
seem to work yeah we I had much much
tougher games when the pawn was on c4 I
think I looked at all of the all of the
games there from the black side what did
I miss miss one no I think I got
everyone I made I made a little print
out here to not forget forget things so
I'm
the issues sometimes here with this is
this moon water is that the lines that
not the kings in the area 96 are a bit
tricky sometimes to play yeah here
there's also D takes d5 not the end of
the world but it is it is possible yeah
yeah yeah
for example it's not so clear what black
is supposed to do here
and I tried 97 okay but 97 Bishop g5 was
not critical 96 is possible but I think
honestly probably just going to the
Kings engine it's the best option yeah
okay I hope you enjoyed this overview of
the the modern defense here's black and
one XIII with white yeah which is in
both cases is highly transpositional and
flexible that's what's nice about those
some those opening moves you can vary a
play a little bit and it's not very much
in the focus of current theoretical
discussions so quite often you probably
will know more than your opponent can be
a good alternative and I have a have
really good experiences especially from
the white side of weaker back them of
this this kind of things I always
started with 93 really because I don't
want to see if I've early on and I think
this can be played quite successfully if
you specialize and it have some concrete
ideas against lines if you just play
like g3 d3 and have no idea you're just
giving up on any hope of an advantage
for white but if you play that with some
ambition and have some idea about
positional and impossible hit
transpositions then you you can really
play it with quite a quite good success
I think okay well I hope you enjoyed
that review thanks for watching